the best nfl
in stadium song experiences i think you
and i both realized this is very broad
and there are a lot of songs out there
that get used in nfl stadiums but i know
for me it wasn't all that difficult to
come up with my list of finalists are
you ready to go i'm ready to go
definitely it's a cool one i'm
interested to see where you go with this
i kind of went you know the traditional
route um my favorite after game song
with anything is new york new york when
the yankees win by frank sinatra that's
my favorite just to let that be out
there but uh let's do this you're going
down florio are you good are you gonna
sing all of yours you know it
all right
sing the coin toss to get it started oh
i'll go with heads today
what the hell was that told me this
really knocked off yes
it worked it was maybe you should sing
it every time go ahead all right
i'm going uh i'm going real old school
traditional here okay this is what i
like it's my damn draft so people can
push back all day one but my favorite
song to do with any football team when i
was in a stadium it gave me chills the
two times i was there as a visiting road
team the raiders anthem okay i wish we
could play it it probably cost nine
billion dollars to pay nfl to have the
autumn wind is the song for anybody out
there that wants to listen to it but
dude
[Music]
you know that one right mike gives me
the chills just thinks john madden
stabler plunkett al davis
mean dudes of the raider era uh to me
that's the one that makes the hair on
the back of my neck stand up mike when i
hear it on tv to this day
you did that pretty well thank you
and they they do that is one of the
things and i'm sure they'll take that
tradition with them to las vegas and
that'll be one of the moments that'll
cause hair to stand up on the back of
people's necks have a feeling we'll be
there one of these days for one of those
moments when that happens during a
raiders game assuming that they can
become relevant once again all right i
like that not a bad choice wasn't
necessarily even on my list although i
haven't experienced that in person so
maybe that's why here's one that i have
experienced here's one that if you find
the videos on youtube it is quite a
moment it doesn't happen every game but
there are certain moments right there
are certain times where it calls for it
in the uh the city where the three
rivers come together in the fourth
quarter and they never know what song or
what game it's going to pop up and all
of a sudden everybody's in the stadium
and they're anticipating and all of a
sudden you hear
oh mama i'm in fear for my life of the
long arm of the law
and uh and that's when you get the
goosebumps and it builds in slowly and
it explodes and they go crazy in
pittsburgh what do you give me if you
get a c minus for that that was pretty
good i mean you gotta renegade by sticks
that's what i was gonna ask you i
couldn't remember who sang that song
exactly but that is an exciting song
definitely and like i didn't know
whether or not i was going to pull that
off i was very nervous about that you're
very nervous i have to admit i was very
nervous about that you look like i don't
want to see that in the best stuff you
still look nervous
it'll definitely be in the best of it's
guaranteed i will not let that not be
there okay but you really did good there
a little voice inflection man i was very
impressed there i didn't even practice
that i figured if i'd practice it would
be a disaster okay go ahead okay all
right um
i don't know where i want to go with
this one i think uh
i'm going to go down to washington dc
for another one that i've experienced a
few times in my life watching my dad
play the washington redskins back in the
day but hail to the redskins okay that's
a song that you know to me when you're
sitting there and and playing in
washington hearing that fan base and
hearing that song and the band i mean
there's not many nfl teams that have a
band i don't know if there's any other
team that has a band other than the
washington redskins but you know when
that goes it's pretty special hail to
the redskins hail victory
braves on the warpath
fight for all dc and i know a few other
words too but that to me is pretty
awesome of course it's got a great
tradition the redskins are a team that
have won uh three super bowls and are
pretty damn good
you are going very traditional with
these i am i know you weren't expecting
this
we're not hearing any of these on the
top 40 stations that's for sure but you
know what i'm i am going to i am going
to go uh europe
there's two different ways i can go here
yeah um
since you're going traditional i got to
go up i-95 from washington to
philadelphia right i mean what have you
ever really fly he goes flying those are
the only words i don't know i'm not
going to do it
something something victory or something
e-a-g-l-e-s eagles but there's that
there's if we're going to go traditional
fight song that that's the one that has
the most punch and even though i don't
remember the words that's the one that
resonates with me the most i i i with
that was on my list i like it too i
don't know the words either other than
fly eagles fly and something on to
victory but when i hear the words are in
the sheets they're in the sheets here
they are oh yes
there's a lot of words there yep there
this it's a good song it really is i
don't know what it is it just makes me
want to spread my wings every time i
hear it so okay i'm not mad at you there
all right here's one a little less
traditional i don't know really how long
they've played it in this stadium but i
know when i was like a nine and ten year
old little boy they were playing it then
and they've played it ever since and
that's the buffalo bills with you took
my throat let's go buffalo hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey let's go buffalo shout
outs guys it's shallow
you screwed up the title all right i got
it but i'm playing i'm playing this
version right now okay so that is really
cool that was really special
to me that was one of the first times i
feel like a a radio hit got infused into
a team's culture to where the fan base
adopted it and kind of made it their own
song i remember being on super super
bowl 25 bills giants and the bills fans
even that day were singing it so uh
that's a pretty cool one it gets the
stadium pretty rowdy
yeah and uh that's one of the classics
from the animal house film which is like
40 years old this year i think this is
the 40th anniversary of the animal house
either this year or next year but uh
that's a great song i almost went with
that one in round two i i decided to
save until round three i didn't think
that you would you would take that one
from me all right i'm gonna go round
three and i got several i can choose
from and and here's one that if you're
not a fan of the packers it drives you
crazy it's nails on a chalkboard every
time they score a touchdown now a few
other teams use this as well but i think
the packers are the ones that it it
resonates the most the old bang on the
drum all day song that they score
whenever they score a touch and they
play it whenever they score a touchdown
and again it does have a nails on a
chalkboard quality to it unless you're a
packers fan i'm sure it sounds very
great and very harmonious and very
pleasing to the year if you're a packers
fan but that's one that when we started
making this list yesterday it's one of
the first ones i could hear in my head
is bang on the drum all day at the
packers games well yeah i got to hear it
i don't know what you're talking about
let me hear it yeah i'm not i'm not
singing it dude you know what i'm
talking about dude
that's not even close no that's not it
it's the song they play you hear that
you hear the synthesizer i don't wanna
work i just wanna bang on a drum all day
good you're not familiar with that i am
not familiar with that at all and on
that pick you need to watch more
football you lost the draft on that one
but i've got no
yeah you were just trying to draw me out
there what else did you have what else
i had uh well i you know when the saints
go marching in was on the list i i uh
you know that's uh that's a big deal in
new orleans obviously and also in
minnesota they play princess let's go
crazy
which is fitting i thought about i
thought about making that my third right
the patriots play uh that bon jovi song
right i don't know the name of it
[Music]
i don't really like the song i like bon
jovi it's one of my least favorite songs
of him but i always find it funny that
that's a bon jovi song i'm pretty sure
it is yeah they play every time they
score a touchdown they play a bon jovi
song which is crazy because he's a new
york giants fan and i know he likes them
too other one i thought about is uh the
miami dolphins you know the star the
song that the houston oilers paid for
but go ahead go ahead what am i wrong no
no no no no no no no it's horrible yeah
i don't know why you like it no i don't
it's so horrible i like it it's like new
england it's like hey we scored another
touchdown you gotta listen to this
horrible song eat that visiting team
that's kind of why i like it um but the
other one the miami dolphins you know
the houston authors bought the rights to
this song but miami still plays it too
you know uh miami dolphins miami
dolphins miami dolphins number one you
know that song you remember that one
yeah i know that song i hate it that's
what i said it's it it it's an annoying
song yeah it i found it last night when
i was doing the research i turned it off
i almost threw my computer out the
window that's how much that song is
annoying and i missed my buccaneers keep
singing it my buccaneer sauce is right
here yo ho yo ho the pirate's life for
me
you know they play that and the cannons
would shoot out of the ship and all that
uh always had fun with that song on the
sideline when they played that back in
the day
i always liked the san diego
supercharger although that doesn't
really fit anymore that's i know you're
right i i wrote it down but you're right
when i started writing san diego i wrote
i guess i can't use this that doesn't
make sense and it doesn't sound good
with uh you know sandy a go super char
you can't you can't trade it off los
angeles superchargers doesn't work all
right i'm done singing the same ring to
it yes all right quick uh summary of
what we have selected for chris sims the
autumn wind hail the redskins and shout
for me renegade fly eagles fly and bang
on the drum all day which the packers
play after every touchdown all right
we'll be posting this i'm sure on social
media we'll have a post at pft
minus my singing you can share your
thoughts upload your own video of you
singing if you want to i don't care you
can do whatever you want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports